hey what's going on it's bill burn it's
time for the Thursday afternoon just
before Friday Monday morning podcast and
I'm just checking it on you oh that was
a good one
the lovely Nia head Nia give me give me
a microphone here I got a pass this
through because it was the wires are all
crossed here I got the wires crossed the
wires are crossed we're sitting here
that better yep me and the lovely Nia we
have on the reason Nia's here is I hit
we have a huge announcement to make
that as of this morning yeah nyan and I
yeah yeah I yes
became two people right that yes
had corned beef hash for breakfast
absolutely we are so proud and we're so
happy and we just want to thank
everybody for your support or support
over the last few months and for your
thoughts during this difficult time baby
isn't here yet so I've been out yet I
become I become like a sitcom dad just
[ __ ] hanging out at the house with my
big [ __ ] socks Bill's got big fuzzy
socks on yeah the only thing that's
right because it's cold in here because
I get hot yeah
we have hardwood floors he is [ __ ]
walking around more pregnant than
anybody I've ever goddamn seen so it's
like she could be standing in Antarctica
being like put on the AC I'm over here
[ __ ] chilly willy so i am i got on my
so pregnant I'm just like a human
tea kettle I am short and stout y'all
baby though you know baby you look good
to me um thank you anyways uh so we're
sitting out here on a rainy [ __ ]
Sunday it's been raining cats and dogs
out here and uh did you say rainy Sunday
did I say Sunday I don't know it feels
like a Sunday it's a [ __ ] Thursday
whatever pouring outside
you know what pissed me off what
yesterday on the news some [ __ ] idiot
like they announced out here in
California they said the drought is over
just cuz it rains well now because it
rains so much that this flooding but
like now this shit's gonna stop and then
this this is going to have to last us
for like four years because you know the
next
she like well how much does it have to
rain for it to no longer be a drought
that's my question well I think just the
mere fact that it's raining mean that
there's no no no water levels in all the
reservoirs I believe I'm just would
guess that this they have to get to a
certain level cuz when I did my bus tour
burning my own hole in the [ __ ]
California ozone sure when we went by
all these big reservoirs that were for
uh you know drinking water or just even
people just ride boats around or
whatever like you could see the water
line I mean it was like - like you know
a brownstone in New York picture like
two or three those stacked on top of
each other that low and and the little
egg was a half mile across to me was
[ __ ] ridiculous yeah it was it was
terrifying to be honest with you so
evidently it's gotten up to an
acceptable level so now everyone's gonna
start taking [ __ ] long showers you
know what I mean you know it kills me
out here every time when it starts to
[ __ ] rain and you wash all you watch
all that water going down the LA River
that goes all the way down to Marina del
Rey I believe and then it just goes out
to the ocean it's like why don't you
capture that somehow and save it all
that runoff yeah I mean I think
environmentalists would like that to
happen well it all right a very
complicated process I lost kids couldn't
have books in schools anymore if we
captured the right way if we did that
then we'd have to cut this and I don't
know it sounds like it seems like it's
complicated maybe it's not I don't know
yeah you have you have no energy today
what can you hear it in my voice
you have like rainy day energy I have
rainy day and pregnant as [ __ ] energy
rainy day in Prague knit all brings me
down well why don't you just [ __ ]
have the kid just [ __ ] you know oh I
wish I could I wasn't gonna have it
right now yeah you know what you know
funny is is I've been like joking about
this on stage is the level that people
have been trying to uh every day I get a
text it'll say did the kid come yet and
I'll say no me and the follow-up Texas
are you nervous
it's like well I wasn't I was sitting
here relaxed like they just get you on
edge and I'm just like it's been this
great process where I'm just like wow
I always listen to people I need to stop
doing that because it doesn't help you
they just think I was joking onstage
like they were getting you like you know
you get a dog all excited like you wanna
go inside how do you want to go outside
like that's what they don't you like is
a baby here
are you nervous you excited I know I'm
getting you bring it out like three or
four texts a day for like the past three
days it's like no babies not here yeah
you sound like you drank some of that
what's that what's that
Frank you sound like you're lean is that
what the kids are doing nowadays with
the [ __ ] cough syrup and their Irish
Spring that they take it cheese grater
and they [ __ ] hair spring that's one
of my favorite things dirty sprite
that's what future calls it I like when
you got all these [ __ ] people on the
internet they show you how to make it
cuz I was sitting I was a comedian I got
to know what's going on
oh did you look online to see how it's
made yeah it's literally sprite and like
codeine like prescription I said and
they take like a custom we'll put a
jolly gesture or some [ __ ] in there but
like if you just look at the ingredients
on the back of the [ __ ] thing yeah
yeah like I gotta hand it to this
generation all these generations every
time you think like you know wow like
like I was saying my generation there
was crack babies and I'm just like okay
that's it that's the end that's as
[ __ ] up as you're gonna see like human
beings do things like like as a parent I
wouldn't be able to be shocked like
you're doing what right hmm
then came meth heads which literally
look like walking dead people they're
not zombies but they're not real people
anymore they have like [ __ ] ate like
when I would do gigs out in the Midwest
you know Iowa in further west into those
states you know celebrities go to buy a
log cabin buy a [ __ ] pretend they own
a grizzly bear outfit right you go out
there and they had like this before and
after pictures of people on meth yeah
yeah and I was just like holy [ __ ] that
that made that blew my [ __ ] mind and
now looking at these guys I mean I guess
this isn't as bad as meth but just
watching beings will always find a way
to get high though new creative ways to
get high thank that's just kind of how
it goes don't you think but I'm a sigh
like an old man here what was wrong with
what the [ __ ] we did can't you track a
couple of beers I mean what that
can drink that they drink it that's like
[ __ ] homeless people do or like like
full-on alcoholics and people will not
[ __ ] give you like money for booze
anymore
and you just don't have it that that's
what they used to do they go and they
start drinking nyquil yeah cos
prescription dread any of that stuff is
really like I don't know I've never
drank that kind of stuff before but it's
supposed to mimic the feel of opioids
I thought opioids or opioids opiates you
mean oh no opioid is that correct right
that's a bump on your ass no that's a
hemorrhoid I thought opiate so that's
opiates opiates but hemorrhoids is also
a word it is I think is that when you
take like the q-tip laced with the [ __ ]
you put it in your ass I don't know why
you are obsessed with the ass but no no
there was a thing that these kids were
doing they was soaking something there
was I swear to God I swear to God I went
down a rabbit hole how these kids get
high there was this [ __ ] thing they
were doing they were taking something a
q-tip or something they was soaking it
in the [ __ ] that got you high and then
they'd stick it in their ass because
there's a thin membrane there leave it
yeah like how people blow coke up each
other's ass and stuff no yeah that's a
thing that is not a fad now you know
what I'll go with the [ __ ] q-tip up
the ass no it totally is the thing hang
on a sec that is not a [ __ ] thing it
is the old coke in the ass yeah just
picture what that looks like what are
you cupping in your hand and then you go
spread it wider wider and yeah no
[ __ ] way probably is like a straw to
funnel it in the enos really and how
well do you know this Hershel I do we've
been friends for a while right you know
I've seen you drink drinks you use a
straw use a straw right that's not
really crazy you know and we both have
asses so I got this bag of coke hear me
out just hear me out just sit out sit
out
that's listen I'm not taking my pants
off I was just adjusting my belt listen
all right coke this is gonna be on my
[ __ ] search engine up next time I go
to the Apple store coke up yes up the
bum up up an anus up the arse off the
arse so it's even in England I got
cocaine blown up my ass so you don't
have to what oh that's advice article of
course it is okay wait Anil use rectal
administration it's this is it drugs
form calm so don't put cocaine in your
butt people that's that reddit uh lively
Kong man blows cocaine up a woman's ass
yeah wasn't planning on it before he
stuck his fatty or anything yeah so okay
wait as well you don't Cyclopedia
dramatical investigate it more just know
that it's a thing that exists all right
well then I gotta look mine up well I
got to read the article here all right
this is what you need some sort of
[ __ ] kitchen knives wait wait wait
let's not tell people how to do it I
mean I guess this isn't real Nia when
the internet was suddenly abuzz with
rumors that getting a friend to blow
coke up your ass with the straw was
worth the trouble I had to see if I'd
been doing it all wrong after all blow
doesn't come with instructions oh Jesus
Christ get to the [ __ ] point all
right I don't there's not gonna be a
video this is a okay okay I know it's
funny I said hoping the conversation
recover but I just wanted to understand
the possible health effects on a more
fundamental low okay so he called
somebody positions viewpoint and a very
nice woman named Kate spoke to me I
asked her about it and she fell silent
he said I know it's funny I said I was
hoping she says it's more sad actually
he said oh yeah that's the word I should
have used said overall Kate was
extremely helpful and promised to
contact all the gastro subber
neurologists still the internet had
spoken I had to try it
not that the duh this guy okay I'm going
to go with the pictures now he's got the
spoon he sticks it in a vial all right
in the end my high was no more
significant than when I opted for the
more or
the docs approach alright so people are
doing it because it was the other thing
the thing I was talking about rave let
me look this up rave drugs ass search
somebody got their booty eaten it and
all in an American festival strange
happenings regarding EDM festivals raves
and drugs strange happenings regarding
EDM festival raves and drugs them dot
thought thought them and going to eat
their ass not really and not what people
are thinking how to smuggle in gear to a
concert Jesus Christ shaking her ass at
a rave party wicked woman I don't know
why I can't move off this topic this is
getting weird maybe it's getting weird
we're not doing it we're just research
like Pete Townsend hey the San Diego
judges are moving up to Los Angeles oh
is I'm saw something online about that
yeah they finally they're returning home
where they belong
they were the Los Angeles charges for
one season the first year the AFL
they're back where they started here
they come round again hey where did Nia
go it's almost like she's having a
contraction dude you got to ask yourself
as a San Diego charger fan after all the
[ __ ] heartache and everything he just
went through and now they're gonna
[ __ ] walk out on you you know you got
to be asking yourself like what was that
off what was that all for you know right
I actually come back as much as they
hated as much as they hated the [ __ ]
the Patriots and Tom Brady and I had a
horrible fan experience when I went down
and I wore Patriots hats not real and I
might realize how much they hated us I
just don't know I just I actually felt
bad for them as fans because it wasn't
that they lost it's the way they lost
they did the old Boston Red Sox thing
what we used to do before we started
winning all the championships was uh we
couldn't just have the decency to just
suck like the Cubs all those years you
know Cubs just sucked they had like two
errors - two error games one of the
early 80s and then they had the [ __ ]
one where they blamed that that [ __ ]
a little nerd you know rather than the
other six people that stood up
I'm also trying to catch the ball they
had to two Heartbreakers that was the
other than that it was a big keg party
everybody stand there with their shirts
off they all live in Wrigleyville they
got money that they're not sympathetic
people you know what I mean
but charge offense you know what I mean
they just like they had that [ __ ] old
ass goddamn Stadium they rode it out
they were down there they came close in
like 95 got their [ __ ] asses kicked
was it 95 or 94 when Steve Young got the
monkey take it off his back wasn't that
what it was Mia uh yeah Steve Young who
claimed the Patriots should have all of
their championships taken away because
of Spygate one of the dumbest things I
ever heard it's like yeah that's great
Steve it's a brand new rule it was
illegal for one game so when it wasn't
illegal because we were doing it back
then
then they should get charged for it when
the rest of the league was also doing it
alright whatever
so welcome to LA we went from no
football teams to tune in now how does
that make you feel are you excited no
yes no say no I don't care I'm kind of
you don't need to tap up and different
you done no I'm okay you okay you don't
even make it you don't look like you're
okay
I can make it it's a good distraction
all right for sure for all the guys out
there and for the ladies had never been
pregnant what does that feel like at
this point if you guys wonder why I'm so
[ __ ] relaxed she's had so many of
these goddamn things it's like somebody
crying wolf yeah yeah crying wolf yeah
now these are you know you should do to
freaked me out here when I'm not there
just throw a glass of water on the floor
and just be like oh just watch me load
up the car someone has suggested that I
do that to you on Twitter but I don't
I'm not original I don't think that's a
good idea
yeah no these are called braxton-hicks
contractions they are getting you ready
for actual real contractions and I've
been having them more and more
frequently just answer the question as
I'm getting closer answer what question
like what does it feel like oh it feels
like an extreme tightening in
your abdomen related to a pain you've
had before getting slugged in the
shoulder that's never happened to having
your big brother grab you by one of your
ankles and drag it back down the stairs
never happened to me oh this is the only
way I can relate to you it's not in the
ear it's like you it's like someone is
in your stomach stretching it out as
tight as it can go and then it slowly
goes back to normal running into the
living room because you missed a big
play looking at the TV and running
full-speed into the coffee table stomach
first
sure stomach first okay there we go I
did that yes I did that on Monday when I
watch three minutes a night when I
watched the Alabama Clemson game now I
know Nia as much you don't like football
I know you heard me screaming when
Clemson scored that last you were
definitely screaming I would be the
worst announcer ever you know like the
great announcers have to be like do you
believe in miracles
yes sir like he did it he did it Flutie
did it they have like something you know
the shot heard round the world whatever
[ __ ] it was the Giants win the pennant
the jet I just went like yeah you were
going crazy there yeah I started like
for the Crimson Tide call me D um I
actually when I was watching that
[ __ ] that game I was uh I was
actually happy for either team winning
cuz my hatred of Alabama is completely
phony I'm not from down south you know I
just picked LSU because I thought that
Les Miles was a guy I thought he was
crazy eating grass and [ __ ] you know
going forward on [ __ ] field goals
having the field goal kicker run down
this [ __ ] Street and slippers scored
touchdowns I was like hey I'll [ __ ]
go with these guys you know so it just
became fun to root against them but it
was also I'm a big fan of history Nia
and he would have tied Paul Bear Bryant
if he won another championship and also
Llyod was saying that Alabama was
overrated because the SEC was weak and
then out so then I was kind of rooting
for Alabama to beat a team that just
[ __ ]
the [ __ ] out of the Iowa State Buckeyes
31 to nothing um I was kind of hoping
for that but then also you gotta get a
room for Clemson they're the underdog
right it's phenomenal this is how much
of a Cleveland guy okay Jason law had
this well I love Jason okay but he has
the disease of being a Cleveland sports
fan
when [ __ ] Clemson went up because
what happened was Clemson scored and it
looked like they were going to win the
game and then Alabama went right down
the field and gave him the old right
there Fred and then Clemson came back
when it looked like there was really no
time left and then they scored and then
they want right
so when Clemson went up and it looked
like Alabama wasn't gonna have enough
time to score Jason texts me about their
head coach saying he'll find a way to
[ __ ] this up and I just wrote back Jesus
Christ Jason can you just believe and
then sure enough Alabama goes down and
scores a touchdown and then Jason writes
to me you Clemson you lose some almost
trying to look like you win some you
lose some or something like that and
then clemson goes down against all of
his [ __ ] negative vibes they go ahead
they score the winning touchdown you
know what he says to me he goes I they
should have won it last year this you
know won last year too they finally win
a championship that's what he says um I
don't know classic Cleveland guy anyways
Nia we're gonna go see a double feature
today huh yes you're taking me to uh
what am I gonna go see we're gonna see
moon are you having another one yes
alright it's a five one one rule so
that's two within five minutes I know
but this isn't a real contraction this
is just the way you never had a baby
this is you guys do at the end of this
[ __ ] thing about said he heard a baby
crying quick Mia what the [ __ ] because I
know this is they say you know you know
when the contraction is real and it's
like if you got to know when to hold
them I don't think I'd be able to wait
to fold and hang out and hold
we need to have a kid ya know when to
podcast
you never couch Oh babies when you're
sitting on the sofa
they'll be time enough for countin when
the Braxton Hicks is done right actly
we're gonna go see moonlight and then
we're gonna see hidden figures this is
all dependent I mean hopefully yes I
won't be mood like and hidden figures my
water won't be breaking during any of
these does this make bill woke day this
is third trimester guy so I got to
disagree with everything that she
[ __ ] says so I got to go see that and
then I got to go see hidden figures
where you know they're going to do a
total over correction of [ __ ] history
and they're gonna have a bunch of guys
running around like what do we do what
are we doing
it's supposed to be a really good movie
and I'm not I had to see it I know and
it's keyword based on a true story Kozma
isn't it Kevin [ __ ] Costner and my
girl Janelle Monae who I love so much
remember one went to see her in concert
we saw before she was famous that's a
famous famous we saw when she was just
famous that's right she was jump around
the saddle shoes when she was opening
for somebody not out she closed now she
opened for Jaime Liddell at the Avalon
don't you remember I had seen her in a
magazine and I was like who was this and
I listened to some of her music and I'm
like that's cool
and then the week of our wedding she was
playing at the House of Blues and I went
to go see her a couple days before our
wedding and it was awesome I went with
my maid of honor they took a picture
together and we ended up hanging out
with her and what did you eat afterwards
what what did you have to eat afterwards
well what are you saying you just get
into a lot of detail here oh well excuse
me sorry I got cabin fever Nia I said
yesterday maybe watching watch i sat in
the [ __ ] laid in bed with you and we
watched all those [ __ ] game shows
yeah we we watched jeopardy waiting for
everyone Oh first we watched the news
we've turned into a real old couple we
watched the news and then we will Donald
Trump yelling at that guy in CNN yeah
and then for 8:00 news your fake news I
won't answer that
let her talk don't be rude the open road
jeopardy and then we watched wheel of
fortune the wheel of fortune got boring
they got rid of all their [ __ ] I used
to have the worst [ __ ] prizes you had
to pick from right in the end they'd be
it was always like for $600 I'll take
the brass bed frame for 560 I'll take
the grandfather clock I saw like old
people [ __ ] 300 bucks I'll take the
estate jewelry oh my god father clocks
I'll take put the rest on a gift
certificate how many people went
bankrupt every other [ __ ] spin yeah
that nerdy black kid every time you
would get a heaven every time Calvin
will get ahead and he didn't win in the
end I was so sad I mean he won but then
he didn't get the final puzzle I think
all the Calvin said world were winners
that day all right Pat Sajak is 70 years
old
Alex Trebek is 76 Alex Trebek is under
contract for another two years this is
this was why my [ __ ] ad D reacts when
I watch a game show cuz after a while I
can't watch those people excitedly
yelling out letters do we co see there
is 2 C's you want to solve a puzzle or
continue spinning how many attendees
paying 350 how is there an L who I'm
sorry there's no L Calvin spin the wheel
[ __ ] drove me insane and I can't even
[ __ ] I never know what it says you
could have everything but the vowels of
sigil can J kitchen titty I can never
honest I never know what the [ __ ] it is
you're really good at sports jeopardy we
watch some sports jeopardy this week we
do a lot of game shows that's true yep
oh my god we killing at sports jeopardy
yeah the [ __ ] that doesn't matter in
life
everything about um speaking of which
how about those Celtics huh Sally yeah I
had a tough one against the [ __ ]
Raptors or the Huskies whatever the [ __ ]
they were doing every when they throw
back [ __ ] jerseys Jesus Christ I
don't know one person's name on the
Toronto Raptors but I do know DeRozan
now holy [ __ ]
that guy just he hit him I thought he
kept saying DeRosa and of course I just
kept thinking about Joe DeRosa it's
getting Joe DeRosa killed him he killed
us on the raptors this the Photoshop
right there I want to see Joe DeRosa if
you can find a [ __ ] picture of him
where he kind of looks confident um you
know Joey when I put him in with that
Toronto Huskies [ __ ] throwback that
guy DeRozan killed this man finally when
he scored like his 41st point I think he
turned around and looked at our bench or
at the crowd and I didn't even make me
upset it's just like yeah dude he could
you couldn't cover the guy we had up we
[ __ ] had him Toronto was exactly what
they were but that's a that's that's you
know that's where we're at we fought we
[ __ ] beat everybody else except for
the people we're going to run into in
the late rounds of the playoffs so it's
looking like the Celtics can went around
or maybe two who knows depending on but
you know that was to become the second
seed in the East which would have been
sweet right because this number to play
70 you know this did you just fall
asleep no no no bad no no you wanna
listen to me read out loud
Bruins got the Predators we beat the
blues iam really gonna put me to sleep
oh you know what what about when I'm
watching your [ __ ] your stupid
reality show sit huh I actually enjoy
them right
I'm not [ __ ] angry anymore dia I try
I'm trying to keep the anger going I
don't have it anymore
okay meditating every day you know it's
funny those me being less angry is like
freaking you out it's not freaking me
out
I literally gave you props all yesterday
when we after the doctor's appointment
we sat there we had a nice brunch and I
told you how proud
it used to it used to unnerve me a
little bit when you were calm because I
just thought yeah yeah okay I was
plotting doing something to you oh my
god our old friends here endo endo Chino
endo Chino is one of the largest
made-to-measure menswear brands and
nothing says I'm happy in my
relationship like getting some menswear
get a high quality suit made to your
exact measurements that's the [ __ ]
[ __ ] man when you got a job we got to
wear a suit you come home like Hugh
Beaumont the beginning of Leave It to
Beaver bespoke means for a perfect fit
uh what's a spoke bespoke what is
bespoke isn't that a suit that's made
exact just for you like all of conor
mcgregor's suits alright guys get some
nice suits
Hado I'll tell you that guy you only
think nicer than the way Knox yeah is
the [ __ ] suit Seaways alright you
will dress like Conor McGregor one day
I'm gonna make it happen yeah then
you'll see exactly how many pounds I
need to lose the thing about Conor
McGregor's isn't [ __ ] [ __ ]
championship shape ok I'm in palooka
shape that's sweat pants and a hoodie
alright you get to you get to customize
your suit just the way you want it now
here's how it works
visit a showroom or shop online at MJ
TOCOM pick from hundreds of fabrics
choose your custom customization from
lapels depletes to jacket linings and
moral that's pretty cool you can make a
[ __ ] really loud suit of something
classy submit your body measurements
place your all don't do that don't
submit your [ __ ] measurements over
the over the Internet don't ever do it
do you think online banking is bad you
submit your body measurements over the
internet the [ __ ] Illuminati starts
making a robot to your exact
specifications and all of a sudden you
know everybody notices that you're
acting weird
you know you're kind of you but you're
not you that's because the robot showed
up one day and you're like hey me what
are you doing here and then it gives you
right there front of you [ __ ] you
know chokes you out with your tie then
you got from Indochina
alright submit your body measurements
place your order and wait for it to
arrive in just four weeks this week my
lesson
can get any primo Indo Chino suit for
just $389 Indochina calm when entering
BRR at checkout that's 50% off the
regular place price for a man made to
measure premium soup plus the shipping
is free
that's Indochina Calm Chino promo code
bar for any premium suit for just 300
$89 and free shipping its ind o CH i and
oh it's like China with an O it's like
out sting would say China I went to
jaddo incredible deal for a suit that
will fit you better than anything off
the rack ever could alright oh here we
go blue apron everybody Oh blue ball
apron blue apron
you know not all ingredients are created
equal Jesus who wrote this that [ __ ]
guy Trump just appointed to attorney
general you know not all ingredients are
created equal some of them God locks
better you know they're just smarter you
know that got better hair oh they they
they sunburn a little bit more my maybe
they can't pants okay I'll give you that
maybe they're better do with a set shot
than a jump shot all right fresh
high-quality ingredients make a real
difference so important to know so it's
important to know where your food comes
from talk about your personal experience
with blue apron oh Jesus you know I
always wore white aprons then I put on a
blue one and you know I felt I felt a
little cooler affordable for less than
$10 per person per meal blue apron
delivers seasonal recipes along with
pre-portioned ingredients to make
delicious home-cooked meals I have to
tell you this guys if you want to
[ __ ] lose weight if you're working
out the biggest goddamn thing especially
become old like me is what the [ __ ] you
put into your body so one of the big
pains in the ass is going to the goddamn
grocery store wouldn't it be wonderful
if somebody just brought the [ __ ] to
your [ __ ] door all measured out you
can just throw it together after you
workout
wouldn't that be [ __ ] perfect watch
the pounds go away suddenly you know all
of a sudden it's like you're going
around the world looking over all of a
sudden you can finally see the head of
your dick again you know oh my god
you're like Christopher Columbus okay
and you and your junk is the [ __ ]
West Indies I
do we really have to read all of this
it's their [ __ ] incredible meals okay
check out this week's menu and get your
first three meals for free with free
shipping by going to blue apron comm / /
you will love how good it feels it
tastes to create incredible home-cooked
meals with blue aprons don't wait that's
blue apron calm / / blue apron a better
way to cook each meal step by step you
know that [ __ ] customized recipes they
got varieties they got a different
[ __ ] recipe every goddamn day alright
lift everybody ly ft lifet you know
about lift right this is like when
you're in eighth grade somebody brings
up something you know something about
sex you know what that means right
you're like yeah what does it mean it's
the app that gets you a ride in minutes
on-demand 24/7 for less than the cost of
a cab please include all of the
following points during your read of
course I will um oh you're back I'm back
I was worried you went and just had a
baby it's better if you tried lifts you
know what I mean with lifts you just
download the app request a driver and
they show up in three-and-a-half minutes
on average looking sweating all coked up
that's really fast
every driver delivers every every lyft
driver is fully vetted through their
ten-point safety standard yeah unlike
those other [ __ ] ones you got ahead and
[ __ ] hands and a foot to step on the
gas pedal you got a job over there
including criminal and DMV background
checks you know you'll get around
quickly and safety lyft drivers are
rated after every ride so only the best
stick around you don't have to worry
about getting into a filthy car with
some creepy dude like they do over there
I can't say the name of them but it
rhymes with Boober Justin Boober oh girl
you know you're the one for me woah
that's boyband [ __ ] right there with
lifts you can tip in the app which
obviously it's to happier drivers nine
out of ten lyft riders get a perfect
five-star rating that's because most
people are too mean to give a tent
unlike rich like Rex Reed right no
they're too mean to not give a tip sorry
some sort of dog show [ __ ] just fell
into my head bigger isn't always better
people
lift isn't the biggest ride-sharing app
but it's the fastest growing in the
highest-rated one I'm talking quality
over quantity thanks to lift you got an
easy way to avoid drunk driving you
never have to bum a ride you never have
to worry about parking
it's so perfect for [ __ ] LA I'll tell
you that right now a lot of people are
actually getting right
getting rid of their drivers with cars
and relying on lifts to get around this
is a brutal read sorry and you know what
I don't blame them well how the [ __ ] do
you know what a white blame I don't it's
a nice guest lift all right right now
lyft is offering our listeners a special
deal get three free rides up to ten
dollars each that's up to thirty dollar
value when you enter promo code burr
just download the free lyft app today
anyway that's confusing lyft is offering
our licious especial to get three free
rides up to ten dollars each also they
take you around the block we all right
you want to go to the store that's gonna
cost you money all right um we're I'm a
promo code burr bill burr enter promo
code bill burr at their website whatever
the [ __ ] it was that I said how was that
was that a good read how come they don't
have they don't have their website in
here do they do you know I had an idea
the other day near can you believe that
I had an idea you you for what um I want
to buy like a 1948 like Cadillac
limousine ok have the hope just whatever
they [ __ ] have the interior look nice
however the outside of the car whatever
okay then you get the powertrain air
shocks all that [ __ ] gas monkey the
whole [ __ ] thing up right and then I
get a [ __ ] I get a driver right so I
never have to deal with la traffic again
I just jump in the back I got a little
[ __ ] bar I got a little humidor some
cigars and then I got a little Wi-Fi
mm-hmm so I get hammered smoke a cigar
do some business calls and then any time
that's right around the city all day no
anytime I want to go out because out
here the big thing with LA is there's no
place to park like you'll pull into a
strip mall that has like ten [ __ ]
businesses and they have like you know
15 parking spots right and they tell the
employees not to park there but you know
they're going to park it and there's
never any play
the park sure if this guy just pulled up
Huawei clockwork and I just got out then
he [ __ ] drove away how much you think
it would cost to have a good to have a
driver does a driver Hong Kong they have
a [ __ ] driver like I mean Jesus it's
down the street like a creep read the
[ __ ] newspaper I think there's a lot
of holes in this fight I think a few
hundred bucks a day for sure
[ __ ] nobody's gonna sit here for
[ __ ] 24 hours for 200 bucks the other
way in car ass yeah the other would you
can definitely hire a private driver
that's just on call for you you say hey
can you get here at 10:00 or whatever I
gotta go here here here and just hang
out until I need you again if you pay
somebody enough they'll do it why
wouldn't I you know what is I like
driving too much but there's those times
like whenever you go into a [ __ ] game
and all that I'm basically describing
having my own lift mmm-hmm you know yeah
cuz I don't like because now it's just
one person who knows where I live
where's those other people they know
what everybody knows where you [ __ ]
live and then they [ __ ] track you
yeah it's like Justin Bieber does Justin
Bieber know those guys do that all the
[ __ ] time they start tracking you
then they listen they hack into your
phone they start listening to you eat
corned beef hash
looking at your rave drugs ass search
yeah watching somebody take a straw blow
cocaine up your ass as you're going like
hey you know I don't feel any higher
than us I guess there was really no
reason to do that let's just do it
through our nasal passages like we did
before
yo that's like something jackass would
have done back in the day and they would
all be laughing their [ __ ] asses off
that was the part of movies I couldn't
share they've done it I could never like
they those parts of the movie where
there was there was always those parts
where they would just do something's
like a pubic hair sandwich or put that
little toy car up his ass yeah do you
think steve-o never had coke blown up
his ass I mean I'm sure that was his
thing for like two weeks
no nothing he did that he's a very
conventional person okay man when he
steps away from the camera he's very
conservative right I've done staying up
with him a couple times you [ __ ]
great guy yeah you've said that you said
he's like a really nice person yeah with
an with an incredible [ __ ] like sense
of humor right really really funny
[ __ ] guy
um alright LegalZoom this is the last
one everybody legalism start of a New
Year's perfect opportunity day at the
bit to hit the reset button for a fresh
start to finally get around to things
you've been putting off for too long
and legalzoom.com is where you make it
happen so whether you take control of
your family's future with a state plan
or finally get your dream business up
and running
don't let legal questions hold you back
sorry just seems Lee's always such dry
copy with these people seems you know
you let that black dude who does the was
it Allstate Dennis Haysbert yeah Dennis
Haysbert are you in good hands he's
Jewish I didn't know that man as he was
he is he Sammy Davis jr. son cuz I know
he converted his last name is Haysbert I
think said Hays burg at Hays boy no all
right the legal world can be challenging
to navigate
that's why Legal Zoom was created over
15 years ago to provide you with the
tools you need the confidence you
already have and then know how to wrap
up your legal needs
and since Legal Zoom isn't a law firm
you know have to worry about expensive
hourly fees instead you can get legal
advice at flat rates from the network
from the networks of attorneys in 48
states they'll help you with the right
estate plan or answer the questions you
have for running your business call to
action make 2017 the year you get your
life in order and get special savings
when you enter promo code bur at
checkout legalzoom.com
there you go alright let's end and let's
talk about Meryl Streep's Golden Globe
speech what did you think about that Nia
did you think it was historically
accurate was it something that needed to
be said it was something that I wasn't
surprised that she said she's been you
know does she does this I wasn't mad at
it I didn't I mean don't think I took
offense to Nia yeah I wasn't mad aside
from the usual thing of like oh good
someone who pretends to be somebody else
is gonna tell us how the world needs to
be run alright
you thought it was a little what's your
fate what's your new word that you
learned Oh sanctimonious you thought it
was a little thanked ammonius I really
don't know what that means
no little holier-than-thou I just did
all those always just cringe-worthy
moments when everyone from Margaret
Moore whatever his [ __ ] name is
Michael Moore Margaret and and Meryl
Streep and all these people gotta be
like guys you know we're living in a
really dangerous time right now I just
really think it's really important for
us all to hold each other and your loved
ones a little bit closer just that it's
filler it's [ __ ] filler it's just
filler I just don't I don't I don't
[ __ ] buy it and then in the end you
[ __ ] attack bread and circus you know
football and MMA yeah like we're all a
bunch of movies and I like MMA yeah how
come they have to be separate but um the
majority of her message I thought and I
think the finding yourself is an art
form huh defending yourself as an art
form from debating martial all the way
to that yeah I'd be our organ can do um
yeah well like I said this is this is
you know Meryl and other actors like her
they have a platform and they feel
passionate about it and so they speak on
yeah you give me one ink that's anything
wrong with that give me one [ __ ]
cause and I'll give you the speech right
now at the top of my head with every
[ __ ] cliche and I and I would be
called brave if anybody gave a [ __ ]
about me God give me a topic well what
do you care about know you is not the
point the point is give me something I
don't even know anything about I could
still give the speech
oh um saving the whales you know when
you look at the Earth from space which
so few of us get the chance to do like I
did in this movie when I pretended to be
an astronaut
most of it is water and the biggest
thing in the water are whales and like
us they also communicate and just
because we don't understand them let me
finish just because we don't understand
them does not mean that they are not
saying something and they do not deserve
a voice that needs to be heard and
despite the current administration
I vowed to continue fighting for these
whales thank you
sorry I kind of petered out but you know
I mean I still [ __ ] did it I still
did it
and then maybe the next day it was so
brave I loved his cumberbund you know he
was glowing he thanked his wife he
thanked the whales
he took his shiny thing and then he
[ __ ] you know I don't know took a
[ __ ] stretch SUV burning low-lead
[ __ ] gas into the [ __ ] sunset
right yeah I just don't I don't I don't
give a flying [ __ ] I don't need a
[ __ ] lecture from an actor on what's
going on I didn't feel like a lecture it
just felt like she was passionately
talking about something that she felt
strongly and you know what if Hillary
Clinton got in who [ __ ] blew the
bankers in 2008 do you think she would
have given a speech about that know how
many people that they've crushed how
many people are upside down in a [ __ ]
house right now no yeah wouldn't given
speech of course she wouldn't have why
because she wears a blue bra and [ __ ]
Trump was [ __ ] red underwear it's
[ __ ] stupid it's like listen to the
Yankees of Red Sox fans I I don't know
I'm beyond it but this has been this
podcast and I want you guys to know I
don't feel that I'm any different than
you I'm walking around enough I'm not
special
okay I'm just a person that decided to
listen to themselves and I feel that
that's what everybody needs to do and
that's not what we're teaching in the
educational system do you not have
something that you feel strongly about
that you wouldn't maybe use your
platform to discuss it's a bunch of [ __ ]
I feel strongly about but I don't feel
like I'm the [ __ ] be-all end-all in
my point my opinion you don't have to be
to yell and all but you have a podcast
that you do twice to placate the flight
gate I feel [ __ ] passionate about
that so you have two times a week where
you have a guaranteed audience of
thousands upon thousands of people
guarantee you something here if I
started going Meryl Streep inish two
times a [ __ ] week I would have no
podcast though I would be podcasting but
no one would be looking at me
- you big Road you're being rode no you
think you see thank you
and you had a chance to talk about like
here this is the thing that I really
feel strongly about I feel like people
should know I want to share you don't
you don't think that you should do that
no oh okay
well there you go how dumb are people
they don't know what's important people
know it's important people in that dumb
I've traveled around people I get I
don't walk around people like oh my god
bill talk slower I can't get my head
around your fall it's not bad it's not
about like patronizing people it's like
hey here's this thing that came up
recently this is how I feel about it I
feel strongly about it and here's why
maybe you feel this way too maybe you
didn't know about this issue
maybe this will maybe help you open up a
little bit more about it hey that's a
great delivery somebody ought to try
that sometime
are you making fun of me no Meryl Streep
was not delivering it that way right
well he was wagging her [ __ ] finger
she wasn't wagging she was getting a
Lifetime Achievement Award and she got
up there like an honorary degree what
were you in Bouie in this year nothing
I like why is she gonna like they've
given her every [ __ ] trophy out there
they gotta give another one yeah she's
Meryl Streep listen she gets all the
awards you know okay
I mean I'm not saying she should get the
[ __ ] awards but why can't you but why
does it bother you so much so she gets
up there and she talks about what she's
passionate no it doesn't bother me so
much I'm just choosing to make fun of it
oh oh okay I find it just cringe-worthy
what I don't [ __ ] want to listen to
uh you know George like Hannity talked
to me about the [ __ ] ozone layer you
know he just passed away you don't I
mean Charles Bronson your [ __ ] well
the thing is you're not big on award
shows period I think they're silly right
and then the speed I understand why you
have to do it I think a lot of people
that go to him mm-hmm
go to them because you have to write did
you have to cuz what it is is you go in
there like uh uh you know you guys
support the project that you're in I
guess it's the family gets [ __ ]
nominated for something I would go yeah
when I go up there
a [ __ ] stand up there on a good day
with Delia but I mean you got to do it
yeah you have to do it because that's
that's part of the thing that you signed
up for uh it's good you know if it winds
[ __ ] the writing staff they make more
money because then they get to be like
oh wait you know I wrote on an
emmy-award wouldn't show or notify an SP
whatever the [ __ ] you get right mm-hmm
you have to play the [ __ ] game yes so
just go up there and say thank you I
appreciate a shiny thing and take a
[ __ ] walk like I just think I don't
like Trump okay I don't like the [ __ ]
[ __ ] he's doing I don't like the people
he's picking but I don't need Meryl
Streep like I once I sit there like oh
wait a minute he's not a good guy like
Oh Thank You Meryl Streep thank you for
squeegeeing my [ __ ] third eye I know
I think it's a UH I think it's one of
those things where you're famous too
[ __ ] long and you just start thinking
that what like everything that you're
doing is a little more important that it
is you know to me I have to be honest
with India like before I got into this
business
no one ever like I'm trying to think
like at least using that technique no
one ever influenced me like I'd like
there's people that influence me like oh
I want to listen to more that music or
oh wow this there's a part of the world
like that I'd like to see that mm-hmm
but like you know I don't see how like
somebody making like a [ __ ]
three-minute speech it's gonna have more
of an impact than someone that you live
your day-to-day with are your parents
mm-hmm you know that's like that gate
that dr. Phil [ __ ] like when they solves
problems and liked while we watch that
[ __ ] - oh right we watch dr. Phil - no
way dude living in the truck oh and we
had watched like Judge Judy we had a
whole like stay-at-home mom day
this dude was living in a truck with
this kid and at night he was in it
during that night he was in a shelter
and they drove around in the truck and
it was just and with this kid with this
two-year-old having him like Gatorade
and sodas and stuff yeah he goes you
know what sometimes the kid doesn't eat
but you know I always try to make sure
you know I feed him what I can make sure
he's got plenty of sugar and caffeine he
said yeah he didn't tell you that like
that was a [ __ ] like that good heat
in the gate he doesn't get him like
bottles of water he gets a Gatorade and
coca-cola this is our Joseph if that kid
looked fine they never show to safe way
me know that was the music niet that was
the music now he looked like a feral
animal roaming around we said he little
a cute little kid yeah he did but he
also looked like a little I don't know
kids are dirty not much I'm gonna tell
you something right now that kid's gonna
be able to figure out [ __ ] more than
most of these goddamn millennials you
know that's at their with their clean
[ __ ] fingernails lice-free heads in
their [ __ ] laptops all right I gotta
get on my day here um all right that's
it that's nod Castle to the movie let's
all go to the lobby let's all go to the
lobby let's all go to the lobby and
negate what we did on the elliptical
all right go [ __ ] yourselves have a nice
weekend you're [ __ ] I'll talk to your
Monday
[Music]
these two a seascape on my listing boat
for the thing carries every home I
invest in a single aa the choice is
yours to be loved
[Music]
hey what's going on it's bill burr and
it is it's the Monday morning podcast
and this is something I have to start
off I got to start right out of the gate
talking about because someone had
someone was bitching at me that they
liked my page but they couldn't they
couldn't shut off my podcast so they
could watch the other videos if you are
new to my page and you listen to this
podcast and you're already bored with it
all you got to do is just scroll down
it's right on the right-hand side and
it's a little X you just click on it
you'll burn half a calorie doing it and
then you can do whatever else you want
to do on the site all right okay Bruce
can you figure that out um anyways
what's going on how are you how was your
week do you have a nice week everybody I
actually had a great [ __ ] week okay
when people do that they ask you about
something and they don't really give a
[ __ ] they're just setting it up so they
can talk about it it's like I knew I had
an awesome week so rather than just
coming out and being braggadocious if
that's even a [ __ ] word and just
saying I had an awesome week I had to
actually act like I was a considerate
human being and remotely gave a [ __ ]
about what your week was like I had an
awesome week this is what I want to get
to you know and people do that and then
you start to talk about your week and
then they they start doing that nod that
wrap it up that really hyper quick
[ __ ] chipmunk nod like and maybe a
little circular motion with the left
hand like let's get to the point so I
can get on and just download all my [ __ ]
onto your spirit all right wow what an
intro that's not going to make me want
to listen to this anyways this is
basically my awesome week I went to the
Improv in Tampa Florida I have to say
that just in case there's a city in Ohio
also named Tampa because I know they
have Miami Ohio which is [ __ ]
hilarious
goddamn frozen state I live in West Palm
Beach Florida
No Ohio stepped outside of Dayton um
yeah so I was I cannot begin to tell you
guys how much dread I was looking at my
first two gigs of this year Tampa
Florida and Houston Texas both cities I
was looking at with dread I'm still
looking at Houston with dread why you
ask is because you don't like Tampa bill
did you got something against the oil
makers in Houston no it's because the
last time I went to both those towns
combined
I think 31 people came up to came out to
see me you know and I'm like a lot of
you guys I'm an older fellow at this
point and going on the road can be hard
sometimes and if you don't believe me
just talk to that Filipino who's singing
for journey
he's already bitching [ __ ] little
[ __ ] you believe that guy [ __ ] guys
singing karaoke in a third world country
and now he's playing the goddamn [ __ ]
la forum and he's complaining about how
lonely the road is because he's been out
there for [ __ ] six weeks Jesus Christ
you know I can't tell what that guy is
just a whiny little [ __ ] or fiora piece
of [ __ ] maybe just knows who he is
and he can actually step outside of this
gun you know dude I really just wanted
to [ __ ] sing karaoke and you know
singing with you guys was awesome and
I'm over it because I know what really
makes me happy my friends and my family
and making little bok choy as I squat in
my hut or whatever the [ __ ] it is that
they do over there a typical American I
don't know where you're from you know I
think you're squatting in a hut eatin
bok choy I mean what bok choy is and
I've had it I think it's Korean is that
kimchi um boy have a [ __ ] that guy you
know I mean why can he just be honest
and just be like you know what I thought
I liked journey's music when I was
singing it once every other Tuesday at
King Fung Wu's Bar and Grill and [ __ ]
the Philippines but uh you know singing
it every nights kind of [ __ ] boring
and I'm out here with a bunch of [ __ ]
geezers who are trying to recapture some
other [ __ ] and one of them the guy in
the keyboards is still wearing this
tight pants and it's just something I
don't like seeing but I don't have
enough say in the band being as I'm a
[ __ ] contest winner Jesus Christ can
you imagine the awkwardness on the road
like this [ __ ] guy you know they
actually went through all the [ __ ]
the band okay
they ate [ __ ] spaghetti every goddamn
week whatever the [ __ ] they did they
lived in a van and they [ __ ] down by
the river and they [ __ ] made it
you know they made it and then they got
no big fight with Steve Perry because he
thought he could go on his own making oh
sherry and some other forgettable sappy
[ __ ] and you know lawsuits all that
behind the music [ __ ] and now they're
back on tour again and they just [ __ ]
pluck this guy you know up out of a
tsunami and now he's playing look I just
wanna how do you [ __ ] bond you don't I
mean that'd be like me last time I
played quarterback I think was just
[ __ ] some pickup game in 8th Grade and
all of a sudden I'm [ __ ] you know I
show up in week week 15 for the
Baltimore Ravens I don't know you know
throw you made the point why don't you
get back to you great week hey why don't
I own up to the fact that I told you
guys last week that my book Carolina
Panthers were my Dark Horse and I
believed in Jake the lone and what
happens i jinxed him you heard of the
Sports Illustrated jinx is a new jinx in
town and you [ __ ] listening to it so
my apologies to everybody in Carolina in
my man I'm going to Carolina
alright let me get back to my awesome
week so anyways yeah last time I went to
Tampa nobody [ __ ] showed up and and
it was really disheartening because uh I
think at that point my HBO special was
out that type of thing and that's when
it really just hit me how [ __ ] hard
this business is and I was really like
wow man what the [ __ ] do I have to do
so I went to Tampa and what happened I
showed up and a bunch of [ __ ] people
showed up and they were great crowds and
I got like you know a couple two or
three partial standing ovations I was
killing it I was having a great time
after my nice month of rest and
relaxation a bunch of fine ass [ __ ]
came out to the cloud babe um a lot
good-lookin broads down there and and I
probably drank too much [ __ ] two out
of three nights was a good time went on
that guy Kyle had show if anybody from
that show is listening tell him I said
thank you it's a [ __ ] great show this
is how cool this is how great the whole
week was I went in to cow head show
right off the bat that guy's totally
cool right off the bat he knows how to
give a great interview I don't have to
do material we're just vibing
everything's flowing and then all of a
sudden out of nowhere a guy one of my
buddies from high school when I had
season tickets to the Patriots in 1989
when they sucked we just all pile in the
back of his landscaping truck with a
half keg of [ __ ] beer and a bag of
chips
he [ __ ] calls up find out he's living
down there next thing you know we're on
the radio together talking about [ __ ] we
did twenty years ago and if that wasn't
cool enough they had an electronic drum
kit there and they came out of the radio
break playing the immigrant song and I
was on the drums playing fighters so
[ __ ] having this total geek moment
and then I went down to the club and it
was [ __ ] you know I'm not gonna say
it's packed but I got into the upper
deck
you know just picture a just picture an
Atlanta Braves game when they finally
make it to the [ __ ] the the NLCS
that's how full the club was it's about
three-quarters full
[ __ ] you guys I was happy with that I
thought there was gonna be nobody down
there so I want to thank everybody down
there so Houston you got to come through
for me okay want to go out and I play
that improv that's underneath that
overpass and that's strip mall where
evidently there's a lot of violence who
dafuq did the research on that one
anyways
I also like when you walk into that one
how it looks like Scarface's lobby it's
just a [ __ ] I don't [ __ ] it milk
anyways why am I sitting on a club that
I'm going to know it's a great time it's
a great part of town and all I know is I
got a I finally got my new hour together
and I'm really happy and it's it's
really it's it's if things are going
good just [ __ ] come out alright for
the love of God but either way if it
sucks I'm going to southpaws guitars so
I'll still have a good time and I'm
gonna go skating at your [ __ ] mall
because I'm a [ __ ] alright so let's get
into the podcast here so I have hyped
what I have coming up I'm going to be at
the improv in Houston and these are the
dates 22nd 23rd and 24th go to improv
to.com for all information and I'll be
selling my brand-new DVD I'll be
standing there like a [ __ ] jackass in
the end because I have no pride actually
I decided something that you know
because there's a lot of guys are like
you know once they get past a certain
level they don't want to stand there
selling merchandise at the end of their
show because you feel like an idiot
sometimes
and I gotta admit I don't I actually
like kind of meeting people left shows
ones are not drunk morons slapping me
too hard in the back and spitting on me
inadvertently I don't mind that [ __ ] but
this is something that I'm not doing
anymore or at least I want to say I'm
not going to I'm who's kidding who I'm
going to do it because there's nothing
worse than bringing DVDs home in your
luggage you [ __ ] bag weighs like 80
pounds but like I hate when I work a
club where I have two shows and however
the crowd walks in there's not enough
room to have the next crowd stand there
and have the other cloud walkout so they
send the first crowd out the side door
and if you want to sell your merch
you're literally standing outside the
club and I cannot begin to tell you how
much of a [ __ ] [ __ ]
I see it in people's eyes to when they
see me like I was doing
I was standing outside the improv and
not Tampa and they have like it's one of
those you know those deals I got like a
sports bar a movie theatre it's all like
this one little Dickens I got an outdoor
mall and I'm literally standing there
and people are going excuse me excuse me
about people who don't give a [ __ ] about
the show who have no idea who I am and
audience members who like give a [ __ ]
who I am really see where I am in this
business in that moment if some plumber
just goes hey hey pasty why don't you
get the [ __ ] out of the way so I can go
see well you know my god what Benjamin
Button
this is going to be a disjointed podcast
I don't give a [ __ ] right I'm on some
new diet I [ __ ] just had 8 egg whites
I'm never doing that again my just
[ __ ] brutal I saw that movie Benjamin
buttons go can you stick with the
subject yes that's what I'm saying I
don't want to [ __ ] stand outside a
club and do that [ __ ] anymore okay I'll
stand in the club there's a table you
know I'll even make the change I don't
give a [ __ ] but I think I'm going to
draw the line and I'm not going to stand
outside a venue dealing with the
elements and people on their way to a
[ __ ] Applebee's as I try to hock my
merchandise because I got admit I felt I
felt felt pretty pretty pathetic pretty
[ __ ] pathetic so um anyways let's get
on let's get on with the podcast here
and remind me to talk about Led Zeppelin
later I don't know how you're going to
do that so I might as well talk about it
now I'm pretty devastated because I
[ __ ] love that group and I had heard
rumors and I kind of knew they had a
couple blues songs that they reworked in
air quotes and they didn't quite give
people credit for it and evidently it
goes way beyond that and there's some
stuff on YouTube I'm always looking at
Led Zeppelin [ __ ] cuz I'm a huge John
Bonham fan and somehow I stumbled across
this thing because I guess the YouTube
guy was just on Howard Stern so there
was a lot of [ __ ] on them about them
stealing material and all I can say is
Wow
it went beyond a couple of songs it went
into I mean every song but two songs on
their first album half the songs on
their second album they're even trying
to say that they ripped off the intro to
stairway to heaven
they had like an opening act on tour
with them I just I don't know I don't
know how to process it and not only that
I just brought my but my nephew the
[ __ ] box set the entire digitally
remastered box set of Led Zeppelin for
Christmas you know thinking I'm the cool
uncle and I just gave him a box of
stolen [ __ ] that's just [ __ ] brutal
check out that Jeff Beck album truth I
just downloaded it how many more times
he literally takes a section straight up
from the guy but you know I think that's
on those other guys they should have
just [ __ ] you know you know what it is
you can't do anything it's nothing you
can do about it they [ __ ] steal they
get credit and they get taken into the
Hall of Fame his [ __ ] brutal alright
that was a bummer
alright did I just say a bummer they
actually kind of worked as I was talking
on music from the 60s that was a bummer
man what a drag
alright anyway so last week I got up on
my soapbox a little bit or my ottoman if
you want to get technical and I was
talking about last week how I'm sick of
going into these places of business and
with this new technology they're firing
fellow Americans and they're making me
do the the fired employees job and to me
that is not progress all right that is
adding another person out there who's
going to be competing for me for a job
while I do their [ __ ] job for free so
I asked people what they thought about
that [ __ ] you know I'm talking
specifically about going into a grocery
store and they want me to check myself
out okay as if I'm somehow going to do
it faster than a cashier that seems to
be the illusion here that that makes it
faster you don't I mean somebody who
actually works there and does it 9,000
times a day
so they gonna have to look at the
[ __ ] keyboard goddamn Stevie Wonder
[ __ ] blowing through it you know and
somehow I'm going to be quicker than
that you know so anyways I asked people
what they thought about it and I got
interesting I got you know basically I
took two of them that kind of summed up
everybody's [ __ ] and then I switched up
some of the guitar parts and I called it
stairway to heaven now wait a minute all
right
somebody said I agree with you new
technologies often make certain jobs
obsolete but they also create new ones
in this case I don't think there are
enough low-level jobs out there to start
getting rid of cashiers yeah and I I
definitely agree with you I don't feel
like they're making you you're walking
into the grocery stores the customer
they're making you be a cashier for free
and everyone sitting there go now it's
quicker this is what this guy's sir this
guy's saying this guy's trying to go
bill as far as the self checkout line
and grocery stores I can't agree with
your take on the situation any place I
have seen with self checkout lines still
have regular lines as well can you
believe that point any place I've seen
with self checkout lines still have the
regular lines as well obviously they're
just not overnight going to get rid of
everybody they're teaching you how to be
a cashier for free and once we all get
it down eventually they're going to get
rid of everybody the same way they're
doing it with like those tolls
those EZ Pass things that it you know
never there was only one EZ Pass line
now it's down there's only one toll
booth line and sometimes you get off the
exit there's no Tollbooth you just
better have the [ __ ] right amount of
change you know I guess that does make
it easier but also lets them know where
the [ __ ] you are which annoys the [ __ ]
on me but I wasn't bitching about that
dude the only reason why ten out of ten
lines are not automated is because it's
a new technology and that's why they
have the douchebag standing there
teaching you how to [ __ ] use they're
teaching you how to be a cashier so they
can fire other cashiers and then they
don't have to pay cashiers and you as
the customer who used to just come up
with your food and stand there and rub
your [ __ ] balls look at
around me don't you understand the
arrogant to that hey why don't you come
into my store pick out what you want you
figure out what the [ __ ] you owe me pay
me stick you stick it in the bag and
then get the [ __ ] out of my store
you'll find a problem with that anyways
this guy continues to say I don't think
anyone is losing any jobs or that
grocery stores are going to turn into
self-serving only venues I'm sorry but
I'm going to stand in I'm not going to
stand in line behind the soccer mom
who's buying enough groceries to last
the entire winter meanwhile all I got is
a box of cereal cereal and milk and now
I have to tell myself I'm doing a good
thing for the workforce by rasuu
refusing to serve myself and the self
checkout line not in this lifetime my
fine feathered friend he really thought
he made a great point there what do you
know what I think you're a [ __ ] what
do you like about that who stands in
line in front of behind somebody who's
got enough [ __ ] groceries for the
winter when all you have is a box of
cereal of milk have you ever heard the
expressed check out eight items or less
have you never noticed that I don't you
know what that data that is [ __ ]
pissed that whole thing just pissed me
off you know what get it's great dude
yes stand in line and go do a job you
didn't have to do before and do it for
free and put somebody else out of work
and tell yourself that it's [ __ ]
quicker the same way they're doing that
on TV where they got that commercial
they try to mine [ __ ] you into thinking
that using your ATM card is quicker than
using cash you know come on man use your
[ __ ] head you know what they're doing
they're phasing out cash so now there's
no more under the table [ __ ] out
there and you're going to get taxed even
[ __ ] more and they'll know where you
are at all [ __ ] times that's what
they're doing alright debit cards are
not quicker than cash and I love the
commercial that they have I don't know
if they're still running it but they
literally used homophobia to try to
convince you you know they think they
put into that part of your brain hey I'm
not sucking dick I'm going to use a
[ __ ] debit card they basically had
this commercial they had a bunch of
people
buying Steelers jerseys I remember
they're all buying football jerseys and
they're going through the line and
everybody's using a debit card and
they're playing that Bugs Bunny music
dontoh didn't that the deadly there and
everything's going great
and it's in people are swiping it once
and they just grab in the bag and and
the whole transaction takes literally
two seconds okay which has not been my
experience ever the guy [ __ ] tries to
put the password in it doesn't [ __ ]
work they swipe it three times and the
cashier finally spins the thing around
tries to do it themselves
it's a big [ __ ] pain yeah so anyways
after all these guys cruise through then
there's you know buying football jerseys
this [ __ ] guy comes up to buy tennis
balls with a pink sweater tied around
his neck and he's peace paying cash and
the second he takes out the cash you
know that that music just comes to a
dead halt and everybody's staring at him
you get it you know football men tennis
pink sweater [ __ ]
I just [ __ ] unreal I don't know you
know [ __ ] this shit's gonna go live in
the [ __ ] mountains I'm tired of
trying to convince people I had this
stupid girl in the front row as
explaining the whole [ __ ] thing to
her and she's like still told me at the
thing that she was going to use the
automated checkout at the cashier at the
grocery store
cuz I go why she goes kinda scrappy how
is it was it quicker you know you could
teach me how to change your [ __ ] tire
I'm not gonna do a quicker than a
[ __ ] mechanic or change my oil or
what I don't [ __ ] it whatever
whatever whatever standing those [ __ ]
lines you [ __ ] drones uh see how
childish I get when people have a
difference opinion this is why I can't
sustain a relationship okay let's get
kid to the quick you know really is I'm
just [ __ ] annoyed that I found out
that one of the groups that I loved has
stolen all this goddamn music
I might do it just you know it was funny
by Led Zeppelin too is they always had
that that cheesy [ __ ] where they were
just like trying to say that they all
sold their soul to the devil
everybody sold their soul to the devil
except for John Paul Jones and that's
why all about that horrific [ __ ]
happened like John Bonham
I'd Robert Plant got in a car accident
this kid died mysteriously and Jimmy
Page I don't know he [ __ ] his eyes
got all squinty I don't know what the
[ __ ] app whatever a Jimmy Page he didn't
lose a finger
that was a guy from Black Sabbath having
a Jimmy Page he had a castle I don't
know if someone having a Jimmy Page some
haven't bad to everybody but you know
what the reason was until they sold the
soul it was Karma for stealing all those
[ __ ] songs inducted into the Hall of
Fame all right whatever okay anyways you
know I should have been more mature
about that some people don't [ __ ]
agree with me on those uh those
automated lines I decide not to me it's
clear is [ __ ] day it's clear is
[ __ ] David yeah I'm not 100% against
[ __ ] like this when I go to the airport
sometimes that automated [ __ ] is quicker
like when you go to check yourself in
for a flight that's definitely
definitely [ __ ] quicker but when I
get on the plane and they start telling
me I need to fold up my blanket to help
expedite the cleaning of the cabin go
[ __ ] yourself alright that's for the
cleaning crew I'm sorry they fired the
cleaning crew I'm not doing that [ __ ]
job I did my job I got on the plane I
said a prayer on takeoff and landing
that we wouldn't crash I didn't try to
open the emergency door or charge the
cockpit I'm done you know I'm going to
take it out a [ __ ] lint brush and a
crumb bar and cleaning up my [ __ ]
area go [ __ ] yourself
I don't work for the airline can we go
hey and I'm getting a new laptop this
week so this is the last time you're
going to hear that [ __ ] annoying
clicking sound trying to do it smoother
all right let's get to the podcast
questions for the week and I got to tell
you guys this is going to be a short
podcast this week because I have a ton
of [ __ ] to do what can I just be nicer
um I appreciate you guys all listening
to my podcast I got glad to go back into
the 700 club guy you know put your hands
on your laptop screen let's say a prayer
for chief no I appreciate all you guys
listening and all that type of stuff and
really blowing through it why can't you
have a sensitive moment bill why can't
you open up
okay take a deep breath let it out I
appreciate the fact that all you guys
listen to my podcasts but I have a lot
of things that I have to get done today
I can't [ __ ] do it I got a lot of
[ __ ] to do alright question number one
bill you often talk on the cast of how
people shouldn't work certain jobs that
help the man [ __ ] in [ __ ] the common
folk one of my jobs I currently work
because I'm broke is essentially
telemarketing and I go home from it
feeling dirty but whose fault is it
really mine or the dopes I'm [ __ ] and
where exactly do you draw the line of
what jobs to not work according to your
personal standards alright telemarketing
I mean that's not making me do a job so
I mean as annoying as it is you can you
can sign yourself up for that don't call
list on the internet if you guys want to
look that up I did that and nobody ever
[ __ ] calls me and but I mean I don't
know what you telemarketing you say you
go home feeling dirty I'd have to know
what it is that you do because you like
I feel really guilty but whose fault is
it mine or the dopes I'm [ __ ] so
obviously whatever you're selling them
is [ __ ] and you know it's [ __ ]
but you're telling them that it's it's
great [ __ ] so whose fault is that that's
yours
I'm gonna say that's yours you know you
know dude you know what's yours you go
home feeling dirty you're obviously
doing some [ __ ] you don't want to do but
I understand any port in a storm I don't
know if you selling people shamwows like
morons like me and I buy the [ __ ]
things you know you're not really hurt I
don't know what the [ __ ] I'd have to
know what you're selling
you know if it's selling those [ __ ]
mortgages that screwed over this economy
then you should feel dirty but I don't
know I don't [ __ ] know I'm trying
anything you know something I used to
tell a market so I can't judge you I
used to sell newspaper subscriptions
over the phone and
you know when you're just doing that
sort of cold calling the only weapon you
have is to lie your ass off and the only
way I got through it was trying to make
the guy next to me laughs I used to go
by Bill McDonald's and the other guy
what the [ __ ] did he get one of the guys
I worked with actually went by the name
Keith Crowder who was the name of one of
the guys who actually played on the
Boston Bruins and we were in Boston he
used to call people up
hey are you doing this is Keith Crowder
calling from the Boston Globe and people
would just everyone said well some of
you like oh yeah Keith Crowder maybe I
go yeah you guys really you play for the
Bruins yeah you go it's my cousin or you
would just say that I I get that all the
time you know what I mean like if your
name was actually Barry Manilow or some
[ __ ]
I know dude I'm not trying to make you
feel guilty I would just try to get out
of that [ __ ] job but do it if you
can't get out of that job I mean what
are you going to do and all depends on
what you're doing dude if just if you're
stealing from old ladies and taking
their their life savings and you know I
had a buddy of mine was doing something
like that and he ended up in jail so you
better watch out whatever you're doing
you know I'm really feeling like I'm
[ __ ] getting preachy and righteous
here and what I don't know [ __ ] just
know that I don't read you know even all
that [ __ ] I just said about Led Zeppelin
actually you know what that wasn't just
YouTube [ __ ] I watched on YouTube and
this kid had the music to back it up so
but anything else is that comes out of
my mouth mostly is [ __ ] all right
question number two bill is there any
way to get links to the individual
podcasts I try to subscribe but I don't
think it worked I'm not really as
[ __ ] as a computer makes me look I
could not identify with you more
that's exactly what happens to me every
time I try to watch or listen to
anything on the on the computer and I
have no idea I don't know how to help
you I really don't I'm like I don't know
I'm like that what the [ __ ] is that that
holiday and commercial you know now I
don't know I don't know computers but I
stayed at a Holiday Inn line
tonight the Holiday Inn Express or
whatever the [ __ ] it is that's how I am
you know I'm on the computer I know how
to put up a podcast but I don't know how
to do any of that other stuff so if
anyway the listening has this
information and what's the email or -
telling me
I'll read it next week and I'll pass it
off as my own just like Jimmy Page
squinty-eyed [ __ ]
alright question number three bill you
must get a ton of podcast questions and
overrated underrated stuff how do you
decide which ones to use in your podcast
I basically any any time somebody if
it's a repeat question like I try to
ignore those but once every six months I
will answer the question how did you get
involved in stand-up but and then just
yet they're good questions I feel like I
can go off on them and they're funny
then that's that's basically how I do it
but if it's a slow week I'll read every
goddamn one of them because I don't get
a ton of them I get like a dozen or so
so I so if you have a question you
thinking like I'm gonna read me in
chances are I will read you got an 80%
chance how about that 80% chance and
that's based on not even mathematically
studying it on any level alright
question of a four bill have you ever
seen two guys start comparing scars are
these two guys just a bunch of tools or
what usually by the end one or the other
has pulled up his shirt or pulled out
his pants
what a bunch of [ __ ] I gotta admit I've
never seen that did you hang out in a
pirate bar I have no idea that would be
weird
oh yeah that's kind of awkward reminds
me of that that scene in Jaws where they
just sit around yeah it's right here
[ __ ] electric eels that me oh yeah
this uh stingray stuck me in the nuts or
whatever now I've never seen that but I
the way the picture you painted I'd have
to agree with your assessment you got to
say something like why don't you two
[ __ ] hacked-up [ __ ] pull up your
pants please for the love of God
look anyways anyway I resent seeing I
resent seeing a middle-aged man who has
a smooth chest and that because they
shaved it just the hair never came in
and they got those [ __ ] five daddy
longlegs hanging off a one nipple and
they don't work out it's just all just
it looks like looks like a melted
snowman that's why I don't know em all
right bill of you and Jim Norton ever
compare to appendix cars no no I haven't
no III this is a whole new [ __ ] world
that I don't want to get involved in
this is some sort of do they have scar
porn this is really making me
uncomfortable
bill besides your appendix scar what is
your best scar and how did it happen all
right I can answer this one I have one
right above my left eyebrow that you can
only see when if I'm imitating the rock
and how I got it was my older brother
threw me off the porch headfirst and I
landed like a lawn dart into a flagstone
this is basically it's basically the
story we had a if you know those those
those porch swings that they have back
in the day where if you if you came if
you were courting back in a day you'd
come and they wouldn't let you go
anywhere so you'd sit out on a spring on
a swing it's like basically a loveseat
but it's a swing and you sit out there
and sing like lighter rows or something
a lot of rows I'm home again Rosia
barbershop quartet would show up like in
The Music Man yeah we had one of those
so somehow my brother pissed me off and
he was swinging like a [ __ ] maniac on
that thing so I grabbed I think it was a
rake I don't know what that it's not
important what the business end of it
was because it's really this story is
about the handle of whatever I grab so
it's a broom it's a rake I don't know
what the [ __ ] it was and as when he got
up to the top
I stood underneath him like I was in 300
you know and I just held that stick up
and I [ __ ] caught him right in his
stomach
and I held them for probably like half a
second and then I dropped the broom
handle whatever and I turn around and I
went to run off of the porch and he had
the momentum of the swing coming down so
he immediately was like right behind me
like you ever watched a roadrunner in
the coyote when the coyote chases the
roadrunner roll around it goes flying by
him and he's at a dead stop and somehow
he catches all the way up to him except
for the last three feet that's what the
[ __ ] my brother did but he had the aid
of a swing so I'm right at the top step
of the porch and he just sort of pushed
me in the middle of my back little
Claude Lemieux action right and that's
when I just went [ __ ] airborne and I
don't know if I ever told you this guy's
the size of my huge head right now I had
this head when I was it was the same
size when I was born so I was probably
11 years old so let's you know for the
sake of the story I'm [ __ ] top-heavy
right so I immediately start going down
like a [ __ ] javelin and it happened so
fast I couldn't get my hands out if I
could I would have broke both my wrists
trying to stop terminal velocity of my
skull and I just [ __ ] went headfirst
into this flagstone and had a nice gash
actually took out a little chunk of my
skull little sliver of it of my
Frankenstein brow and I just remember
getting up and I went back up to the top
of the porch and I was leaning over the
banister because I didn't want to start
bleeding in the house because I knew my
dad was going to freak out because he
already had to stitch me up
my dad's a dentist so uh it's kind of
cool anytime you got stitches it you
know you didn't have to go to the
hospital he just [ __ ] it was like go
like in between periods they just sew
you up on the bench he just kept to it
right there and we you know it's funny
we always ended up having to get
stitches on his day off
poor bastard used to work like three
weeks in a row we get one day off and
then one of us would fall out of a tree
or accidentally in air quotes throw a
[ __ ] Rockets at you no I did that one
and we always use the same excuse I was
running through the woods and I tripped
and if you like outs a chrissake
need this [ __ ] then he's [ __ ] you da
just lay it down on the sofa
you don't nummis up he starts stitching
this up maybe going ah ah and he'd be
like come on stop it stop it that
doesn't hurt that bad and yeah then
you'd have a [ __ ] scarf there you go
that's my do I have any other ones I got
bit in the face by my own dog that was a
good one where this little west highland
terrier and we just kept [ __ ] with
them um I don't know why I can't
remember why at this point so [ __ ]
long ago we basically turned him into an
attack dog we started off just
roughhousing with them and then he would
bite us a little too hard and then we
moved on to a garden gloves and we
started playing what we called the glove
game and we just keep pushing him in the
face and then he figured out how to bite
so then we moved on to I think like
hockey sticks and we just you know
wouldn't hit him really hard we just
sort of like a cleanly trying to dig out
the puck in the corner we kind of do
that [ __ ] and he'd start biting at it
and I remember when he when he would
bite down on it and he finally learned
to start shaking it going like Oh doing
that [ __ ] we thought it was the funniest
[ __ ] ever you know we were all like ages
2 to 10 you know this is back in the day
to when you know there was no Oprah
Winfrey so people didn't know that you
shouldn't leave [ __ ] 5 kids under the
age of 10 at home with a dog and
electricity you know and say yes we just
turned to starting to a [ __ ] attack
dog and we really taught him how to bite
and we thought it was hilarious until he
started doing it to us and so one day my
brother sitting on the couch he's eating
a sandwich and my dog sitting there
sitting up begging you know little [ __ ]
little terrier so I start crawling up
next to him just going eh I'm going to
get the food I'm going to get the food
he's sitting on her alright
he keeps looking over at me and I just
kept creeping up going I'm going to get
the food and then he started doing like
that half a [ __ ] smile show me his
fangs and we're laughing laughing that's
always do just driving [ __ ] the same
way we do to my little brother just piss
them off which is fun to watch somebody
lose their [ __ ]
and the dog was no exception and then I
know what happened I took it too far
and he just lunged over to bite me and I
was my face was at his face his level
and he just grabbed me on the same side
the same side where my brother threw me
off the porch
he [ __ ] sunken just below my eye into
my cheek and then one of his lower
canines was actually inside my mouth and
he had my entire [ __ ] left cheek and
he went liked it and he knew we [ __ ]
up too because he's getting me on the
leg and he didn't give a [ __ ] but when
he did down when he was like oh [ __ ]
that's easily a ten minute misconduct if
not a [ __ ] game suspension yeah and
that was it was a there was a rough walk
into the bathroom I remember that no I
get hurt
it kind of felt like I was just like I
was worried I was going to be deformed
so that was a thing like I was going to
look in the mirror oh my god am I gonna
look like a like somebody just got
bitten and faced by a [ __ ] terrier
and somehow I did he kind of they were
like puncture wounds I still see him and
I'm looking at Mare right now it kind of
faded away I got the one on my upper lip
I [ __ ] know but then I had to go in
my dad's office and he was already
working on other people so he was pissed
it was also embarrassing the next day
when I went to school you know face is
all bruised up when I had stitches for
having your face how's that guy get bit
by a dog whose dog my dog and like did
you get rid of it
no why not because my family is [ __ ]
in the head what do you think you know
dogs not supposed to do that [ __ ]
they're supposed to you know chase
frisbees and be skipping along with you
as you walk back from catching catfish
right I'm not supposed to bite you in
the [ __ ] face but you know I deserved
it so there you go there's my scar
stories for the week I didn't get a
chance to get too underrated overrated
this week I'll just add to them next
week we'll have a giant we'll have a
bonus section of underrated overrated
because there was some really good ones
this week and and that is it um
what do I got what I got a hype real
quick oh please please come see me at
the improv in Houston Texas go to improv
the number two dot-com or you can click
on the link right on my homepage and
Boston I am a big trip back to Boston
February 6 and I'm not trying to be a
cheeseball here but tickets are [ __ ]
it's selling like hotcakes such a
ridiculous [ __ ] statement it's
selling like hotcakes
really who came up with that you know
you know what I'm having an American try
to explore that comedic lee because that
is just such a hacky like wannabe Jerry
Seinfeld [ __ ] bit you know so in my
context what's the real good was there a
period of bourbon everybody was ok um I
like how I said I wasn't going to do
that then I just did it what do you
think about that you know
so right now you guys should just be
shutting up the podcast because I've
obviously established the fact that that
I'm not a man of my word you know I work
with this comedian Ryan Dalton this
weekend and I was going to do something
I really [ __ ] it up I was meaning to
try to get some girl to show her tits at
the end of the show and we were trying
to come up with the way to do it you
know I was going to do in a silly way
like come on man the economy's bad you
know just just do it for America
just make it silly you know there'd be
one girl be willing to do it and then we
try and thinking about like reverse
psychology like yeah you know I'd you
know keep it go over Ryan didn't he if
they need a great comedian I'll tell you
but he's really bashful offstage the
other night this girl was shown a tetany
he just turned all beet red is one of
the funny you know try to [ __ ] make
it look like he's not a little [ __ ]
creep you know the reality was was I
wanted to see some titties and I was
using him as an excuse and I kind of
forgot to do that you know I was really
upset with myself because if I stuff I
miss a joke I forget to do a joke I
don't give a [ __ ] I'll do the joke next
show but you know when you miss out on
titties you know that one sticks with
you alright that's it that's the podcast
for this week thank you for listening as
always
everybody have a great week and wow my
Christmas city is [ __ ] dead this
thing is [ __ ] dead look how dry and
brittle this thing is sorry buddy
Christmas is over
all right everybody have a good week
talk to you later all right
[Music]
well
needs a change
[Music]
and the cheese
citing a
[Music]
and along the way they try they be oxy
legs I'm off tonight can't lie to me
slave no I give it on to a smoother time
I'm victim to the
[Music]
this
ah
[Music]
below